if you feel like the American dream of
hardwork and financial security isn't
working for you you're not alone 58% of
all new income is going to the top 1%
that's a rigged economy - my bike so
what is a rigged economy it works like
this the rich get richer and use their
money to influence politicians who then
make policies that keep the wealth
flowing to the top get this the top
point one percent of Americans own
almost as much wealth as the entire
bottom 90% and they can afford to make
sure the system keeps the money flowing
one way up in the 70s a CEO made around
30 times as much money as a regular
employee now they make 300 times as much
as a regular worker whose wages have
been stagnating since then in fact
adjusted for inflation wages for most of
us have actually been going down since
2009 but at least the super-rich are
paying their share of taxes right well
not quite
most people make money earning a salary
but the super-rich make most of their
money from investments known as capital
gains and even though that's a lot of
money it gets taxed at much lower rates
than wages and speaking of taxes the
super wealthy and big corporations have
the cash to employ expert accountants to
help them take advantage of all kinds of
loopholes and pay the least amount of
tax as possible with that money saved
big businesses and wealthy individuals
have lots of cash to throw at the
political system to influence it after
all politicians rely on donations to
finance their campaigns thanks to the
Supreme Court decision in Citizens
United
corporations are able to spend unlimited
amounts of money in elections using
super PACs we're talking tens of
millions of dollars the maximum an
individual can give just $5,000 if they
have it don't think the money stops when
the votes are counted lobbyists for
businesses and wall street woo
politicians and influence legislation
sometimes they even write it remember
back in 2008 when the bank's crashed the
economy Congress wrote something called
the dodd-frank act
banks and make sure they couldn't do
that again but big banks pushed back
hard and they want the final version of
the bill that came out of Congress was
found to be exactly city bank's proposal
so in fact they didn't change it at all
city bank said this is what we want and
that's what got passed here's what
happened to the rest of America millions
of jobs lost hundreds of thousands of
homes foreclosed on retirement accounts
drained and dismal job prospects for new
graduates
Wall Street's recklessness ruined the
American economy but virtually nobody
went to jail in fact the government
bailed out many of the big banks using
trillions of dollars of our tax money
despite increasing profits Wall Street
is still subsidized by taxpayers it's
not surprising considering the revolving
door between Washington and Wall Street
you have former Wall Street folks
working in the government to regulate
banks and you've got government workers
moving on to lucrative Wall Street jobs
so if the economy is rigged in a way
where money and politics ultimately
serve the super-rich then who's looking
out for the average American
you